This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And it's baseball season. If you haven't watched a game in a while, it can be a little confusing to jump back in. Major League Baseball has introduced a lot of rule changes in the last few years, including a countdown clock for pitchers to make the game go faster. They've also made it a rule that pitchers have to show their hands to the umpire between innings to make sure that the players aren't using any gooey substances to get an extra strong grip on the ball.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。棒球赛季又到了。如果你有一段时间没看比赛了，重新看可能会有点困惑。美国职业棒球大联盟在过去几年里引入了许多规则更改，包括为投手设置倒计时时钟以加快比赛节奏。他们还规定，投手在局间必须向裁判展示双手，以确保球员没有使用任何粘性物质来增强对球的抓握力。
But this season, the one rule change that everybody is talking about is the introduction of robot umpires. Starting in 2026, if a player doesn't like a ball or a strike call, they can appeal to a robot arbitrator called the ABS System, who can overturn the call. And that one's going to be challenged. Body gets it right. Reverse from a strike to a ball. You may remember the name ABS System, because.
但这个赛季，每个人都在讨论的一个规则改变是引入了机器人裁判。从2026年开始，如果球员对好球或坏球判决不满意，他们可以向一个名为ABS系统的机器人仲裁员申诉，该系统可以推翻判决。而这一个判决将会受到挑战。接球手接住了。从好球改判为坏球。你可能还记得ABS系统这个名字，因为
because we talked about it back in 2023. Today, we're going to replay that episode, and then I'll be joined by producer Chris Perube, for an update on how the robot umpires are doing now that they've reached the major leagues. All right, play ball. If you're a baseball fan, you might remember the 1997 playoffs.
因为我们在2023年讨论过它。今天，我们将重播那一集，然后制作人克里斯·佩鲁韦将加入我的节目，为我们更新机器人裁判进入大联盟以来的现状。好了，比赛开始吧。如果你是棒球迷，你可能还记得1997年的季后赛。
That's when pitcher Levan Hernandez was unstoppable. Can Levan Hernandez get out of it? Yes, he can. Hernandez was a rookie for the Florida Marlins, and his masterpiece was game five of the National League Championship Series against Atlanta. That's producer Chris Barubei. Levan Hernandez struck out 15 batters that game, which for context, is so many batters. Strike three is 11. It was an incredible night, but a lot of his strikes, they weren't actually strikes.
那是投手勒万·埃尔南德斯不可阻挡的时候。勒万·埃尔南德斯能摆脱困境吗？是的，他可以。埃尔南德斯是佛罗里达马林鱼队的一名新秀，他的代表作是对阵亚特兰大的国家联盟冠军赛第五场比赛。那是制作人克里斯·巴鲁贝。勒万·埃尔南德斯在那场比赛中三振了15名打者，作为背景，这真的是非常多的打者。第三个好球是第11个。这是一个令人难以置信的夜晚，但他的许多好球，实际上并非真正的好球。
Hernandez was pretty consistently missing the zone. The three-two pitch. Punches him out on what McGriff thought was born for. It's his 15th. This pitch is, I would say, a foot, two feet outside of the strike zone. Not close called a strike. That's baseball analyst Katie Nolan. She vividly remembers that game because it really was not good.
埃尔南德斯相当稳定地投出了好球区之外的球。三好两坏的投球。三振了麦格里夫，而麦格里夫本以为那是坏球。这是他的第15个。这个球，我要说是偏离好球区一英尺、两英尺。离得并不近却被判了好球。那是棒球分析师凯蒂·诺兰。她对那场比赛记忆犹新，因为那实在太糟糕了。
I mean. Okay, second pitch, way outside called a strike. Egregious. Egregious. Katie and I rewatched video from that game with, let's call it, a perverse fascination. Almost none of the batters actually swung at his pitches. You see, Hernandez just winding up and throwing ball after ball like a foot outside the strike zone. And then, inexplicably, the umpire Eric Gregg, he just kept making the hand signal for a strike.
我是说。好吧，第二个球，明显在外面却被判了好球。太离谱了。太离谱了。凯蒂和我带着可以说是病态的迷恋，重新观看了那场比赛的录像。几乎没有打者对他的球挥棒。你看，埃尔南德斯只是摆好姿势，一个接一个地投出偏离好球区足足一英尺的球。然后，莫名其妙地，裁判埃里克·格雷格，就一直做出好球的手势。
It was so bad. It was probably the worst umpiring I can remember. The outside of this strike zone, it just didn't end. It was like a never-ending strike zone. In case you don't know anything about baseball, in the major leagues, there are four umpires on the field, one behind each base and one behind home plate. The home plate umpire has the most important job, which is calling balls and strikes. A strike is basically any hitable pitch, something over the plate between the batter's chest and his knees, and a ball is everything else.
这太糟糕了。这可能是我记忆中最糟糕的裁判判罚了。这个好球区的外部，简直没有尽头。就像一个永无止境的好球区。如果你对棒球一无所知，在大联盟中，场上有四名裁判，每个垒包后方各一名，本垒后方一名。本垒裁判的工作最重要，那就是判决好球和坏球。好球基本上是任何可以击打的球，也就是在好球区上方、介于打者胸部和膝盖之间的球，而其他所有球都是坏球。
I remember watching games as a kid, and whenever an umpire blew it, I would say, I could do better than that. And so I tried. I was a little league in high school umpire from the age of 14 until my early 20s. And I think I could have gone pro if it weren't for my poor eyesight, my aversion to getting yelled at, and the time I was hit in the throat by a baseball. My point is, even in the Little League's, getting calls right is a lot harder than it looks. And at the pro level, the baseball is moving at like 95 miles an hour.
我记得小时候看比赛，每当裁判做出糟糕判罚时，我就会说：“我做得比那更好。”于是我尝试了。我从14岁到20岁初一直在当小联盟和高中的裁判。我想如果不是因为我视力不好、讨厌被人吼，以及有一次被棒球击中喉咙，我本来可以打职业的。我的意思是，即使在小联盟，把判罚做对也比看起来要难得多。而在职业水平上，棒球的移动速度大约是每小时95英里。
It's kind of incredible that on average, umpires get it right about 94 to 97% of the time on strike calls. And umpires are getting better. The worst umpire today would have been upper tier in 1997. But the crazy high speed of the baseball means sometimes umpires are going to get it wrong. It just feels to me like it's asking a lot of the umpire to be able to recognize if it nickedy inside of the strike zone on its way over the plate or if it didn't. And I know we all make fun of the egregious calls, but I feel like some of them, you're not standing back there. You're not having to do it entirely with your eye.
平均而言，裁判在好球判决上有94%到97%的时间是正确的，这简直有点不可思议。而且裁判们正在变得更好。今天的最差裁判放到1997年也能算高水平了。但棒球极高的速度意味着裁判有时还是会判错。在我看来，要求裁判在球飞过本垒时能够辨别它是否擦过好球区的内侧，这确实对裁判要求太高了。我知道我们都在取笑那些离谱的判罚，但我觉得其中有些球，你又没站在那个位置。你不可能完全靠眼睛来做到这一点。
It's got to be really difficult. One study from 2018 found that umpires blow about 14 calls every game. That's 34,000 bad calls every year. And it makes a difference, like in the Levan Hernandez game. The Florida Marlins came out on top, and a few weeks later, they won the World Series. These calls can make all the difference between a win and a loss, a championship, and sitting at home for six months, just wondering what could have been if he'd only made the right call. Given the human fallibility of umpires,
这一定非常困难。2018年的一项研究发现，裁判每场比赛大约会漏判或误判14次。这意味着每年有34,000次糟糕的判罚。这确实会产生影响，就像在勒万·埃尔南德斯的比赛中一样。佛罗里达马林鱼队最终获胜，几周后，他们赢得了世界大赛冠军。这些判罚足以决定胜利与失败、冠军，以及在家坐上六个月，只是反思如果当时判对了会是怎样的情景。鉴于裁判作为人类的易错性，
Major League Baseball has been considering something drastic, something that would take us up to 100% accuracy. They have a plan to replace human umpires with robots. Like any scenario where a human being is being replaced by a robot, there is the question of whether robots can do a better, more accurate job. And in baseball, a sport that is legendary for its quirks and its general human imperfection, there's another trickier question.
美国职业棒球大联盟一直在考虑一些激进的举措，一些能让我们达到100%准确率的举措。他们有一个用机器人取代人类裁判的计划。就像任何人类被机器人取代的情景一样，这里存在一个问题，即机器人是否能做得更好、更准确。而在棒球这项以其怪癖和普遍的人类不完美而闻名的运动中，还有另一个更棘手的问题。
Is more accurate what we actually want? The idea of replacing an umpire with a machine isn't new. In the 1950s, the Brooklyn Dodgers tested a robot umpire designed by General Electric. The GE umpire was a big machine. It kind of looked like a barbecue hooked up to a specially tricked out home plate. If the ball cast a shadow over the plate, the machine would light up a big red button indicating a strike. The trouble is the machine didn't work very well.
更高的准确率真的是我们想要的吗？用机器取代裁判的想法并不新鲜。在20世纪50年代，布鲁克林道奇队测试了由通用电气设计的机器人裁判。通用电气裁判是一个大机器。它看起来有点像连接在一个特制本垒上的烧烤架。如果球在好球区投下阴影，机器就会点亮一个标志着好球的大红按钮。问题是这台机器并不好用。
It made a lot of bad calls. And if it was a night game, the robot umpire just didn't work at all. In the 1950s, the technology just wasn't ready. And the robot umpire went nowhere. For years, the idea seemed like a non-starter. But a few years ago, the commissioner of Major League Baseball, Rob Manfred, said he was considering robot umps for the big leagues. The robot umpires of the 21st century are a lot more sophisticated than a moment. barbecue. But modern robot umpires, they aren't technically robots.
它做出了很多糟糕的判罚。而且如果是夜场比赛，机器人裁判根本无法工作。在50年代，技术根本还不成熟。机器人裁判计划也就不了了之了。多年来，这个想法似乎是一个不可能实现的起点。但几年前，美国职业棒球大联盟专员罗伯·曼弗雷德表示，他正在考虑为大联盟引入机器人裁判。21世纪的机器人裁判比当年的烧烤架要复杂得多。但是现代的机器人裁判，从技术上讲并不是机器人。
That's what a lot of people picture is, is like, you know, beep, boop, boop, kind of a metallic thing behind home plate. What it really is, it's this system. That's Zach Helfend. He's an editor and sports writer at The New Yorker. And today's version of the robot umpire is actually a series of HD cameras. But for some reason, the name integrated camera baseball tracking system has never caught on. So for this story, we're just going to keep calling them robots. I prefer robo. I just think robo sounds better.
这就是很多人想象的那样，你知道的，哔、波、波，本垒后面那种金属质感的东西。它实际上是什么呢？它是这样一个系统。那是扎克·赫尔芬德。他是《纽约客》的编辑兼体育作家。如今版本的机器人裁判实际上是一系列高清摄像机。但出于某种原因，“集成摄像机棒球追踪系统”这个名字从未流行起来。所以在这个故事中，我们还是管它们叫机器人。我更喜欢“罗博”（robo）。我只是觉得“罗博”听起来更好。
Baseball won't be the first sport to use robos to referee games. In tennis, there's a tracking system called Hawkeye that can pinpoint whether a ball is in or out of bounds. And it was good. What a shot. And in soccer, they use motion tracking cameras to help determine off sides and whether the ball has crossed the goal line. And the goal has been disallowed. In fact, most Major League Baseball stadiums already have a sophisticated ball tracking system in place. Those were installed in the early 2000s for TV broadcasts to give fans a clear picture of what happened during every pitch.
棒球不会是第一个使用机器人来执法的运动。在网球中，有一个名为“鹰眼”的追踪系统，可以精确指出球是在界内还是界外。这球真棒。好球！在足球中，他们使用动作追踪相机来帮助判断越位以及球是否越过球门线。进球无效。事实上，大多数美国职业棒球大联盟的球场都已经安装了复杂的球追踪系统。这些系统是在21世纪初为电视转播安装的，旨在让球迷清楚了解每次投球过程中发生的情况。
To track things like exit velocity off the bat, how fast the ball is moving off the bat, spin rate. It counts every single revolution of a baseball from when it leaves a pitcher's hand to when it gets to the plate. So they have these very sophisticated missile tracking systems, essentially, in ballparks. By the way, he is not exaggerating. This is based on missile tracking technology. If you've watched a baseball game on TV, you've seen this tracking system in action. In replays, broadcasters will show you charts and scatter plots to lay out where the ball landed inside the strike zone. But the umpires, the people actually making the calls, don't have access to this information.
用来追踪诸如击球初速度、球离开球棒时的速度、旋转速率等数据。它计算棒球从离开投手手心到到达本垒的每一次旋转。所以，它们在球场里基本上拥有这些非常复杂的导弹追踪系统。顺便说一句，他并没有夸大其词。这是基于导弹追踪技术。如果你在电视上看过棒球比赛，你就见过这个追踪系统在实际运作。在回放中，转播商会向你展示图表和散点图，以标明球落在好球区的哪个位置。但是裁判，也就是真正做出判罚的人，却无法获得这些信息。
Only viewers do. which creates some awkward moments for fans. Wait, if we know that's a strike, why is he calling it a ball? It just doesn't make sense. Why doesn't he have the information I have? He should make the right call. But look, baseball is a pretty conservative sport. It's slow to embrace change.
只有观众才能看到。这就给球迷造成了一些尴尬的时刻。等等，如果我们知道那是好球，为什么他判了坏球？这根本说不通。为什么他没有我得到的信息？他应该做出正确的判罚。但听着，棒球是一项相当保守的运动。它对拥抱变化的反应很慢。
So for now, robot umpires are being tested on the minor leagues to work out some of the kinks and to help fans get used to the whole concept. Since 2019, robot ump technology has been working its way through the minor leagues, where it's called ABS for automatic balls and strikes. Last year, the ABS made its way to AAA, the highest level of minor league baseball. I wanted to see this robot umpire, okay, ABS system, in action. So I bought a ticket to watch some minor league baseball last summer
所以目前，机器人裁判正在小联盟中进行测试，以解决一些问题并帮助球迷适应整个概念。自2019年以来，机器人裁判技术一直在小联盟中推进，在那里它被称为ABS，即自动好坏球系统。去年，ABS进入了小联盟的最高级别——三A（AAA）。我想亲眼看看这个机器人裁判，好吧，就是ABS系统在运作。所以去年夏天我买了一张票去观看小联盟棒球比赛。
in fabulous El Paso, Texas, where the hometown chihuahuas were taking on the Albuquerque isotopes. But I got COVID, so I had to watch the game at home. The field and the isotopes. in position. Riley Smith will start his last eight final warm-up tosses before we get underway with tonight's game. Coming into the game, I was worried the baseball experience would feel totally different without the umpires, because for me, they're essential to the fabric of the game. But actually, I didn't miss the human umpires, because they were still there. Fans here are tonight's umpires. Behind home plate is Dylan Wilson.
在风景迷人的德克萨斯州埃尔帕索，家乡的吉娃娃队正在对阵阿尔伯克基同位素队。但我得了新冠，所以不得不呆在家里看比赛。球场和同位素队。就位。莱利·史密斯将在今晚的比赛开始前投出他的最后八次热身球。在观看比赛之前，我曾担心没有了裁判，棒球体验会感觉完全不同，因为对我来说，他们是比赛结构中不可或缺的一部分。但实际上，我并没有怀念人类裁判，因为他们依然在那里。今晚的裁判是现场的球迷。本垒后方是迪伦·威尔逊。
down the first baseline, Cody. For those you worried about robots coming for human jobs, at least in this case, the humans are safe. Baseball still needs humans for lots of important jobs, like calling timeouts or cleaning home plate with those tiny, adorable brooms. This robot umpire was actually a collaboration between the ABS system that made the call and the human umpire who said it out loud. I listened with the earpiece along to a minor league game, and it's more or less instantaneous.
一垒边线是科迪。对于那些担心机器人会抢走人类工作的人来说，至少在这个案例中，人类是安全的。棒球仍然需要人类来完成许多重要的工作，比如叫暂停或用那些微小可爱的小扫帚清理本垒。这个机器人裁判实际上是做出判罚的ABS系统与大声宣判的人类裁判的合作。我戴着耳机收听了一场小联盟比赛，这个过程几乎是即时的。
The ball hits the glove. You kind of hear the smack of the ball in the glove, and a split second later, you hear strike or ball. And it's funny, the strike is very peppy and, you know, sounds very encouraging, and the ball is ball, kind of disappointed. It's a man's voice just saying ball or strike. ball strike ball strike that's Fred DeHesus he was actually the first umpire to use the ABS system in 2019
球击中手套。你能听到球撞击手套的啪的一声，几分之一秒后，你就会听到“好球”或“坏球”。有趣的是，“好球”这个词非常欢快，你知道的，听起来很受鼓舞，而“坏球”就是“坏球”，听起来有点失望。这是一个男人的声音在说坏球或好球。坏球、好球、坏球、好球。那是弗雷德·德赫苏斯，他实际上是2019年第一个使用ABS系统的裁判。
fun fact his earpiece is now part of the collection at the baseball Hall of Fame I obviously couldn't get there as a player so I made my earpiece made it my joke is six Puerto Ricans have made it and one Puerto Rican's earpiece has made it
趣事：他的耳机现在是棒球名人堂藏品的一部分。我显然无法以球员身份进名人堂，所以我把我的耳机送进了名人堂。我的笑话是：六个波多黎各人进去了，还有一个波多黎各人的耳机进去了。
Fred says at first he was wary about the ABS, but he came around pretty quickly. You know, when in Rome you do what the Romans want, they wanted you to follow the system, you call it. I know this collaboration sounds, you know, a little ridiculous, but watching the game, I was pleasantly surprised. It was pretty smooth. It didn't look like a game umpired by a sophisticated missile robot.
弗雷德说，起初他对ABS持谨慎态度，但他很快就转变了看法。你知道的，入乡随俗，他们想让你遵循这个系统，你就怎么判。我知道这种合作听起来有点荒谬，但在观看比赛时，我感到惊喜。它相当流畅。它看起来不像是一场由复杂的导弹机器人主导的比赛。
It just looked like a regular afternoon at the ballpark. And so here's Bernard, right-handed hitter against the lefty groom from the full wind-up first pitch. There are no publicly available statistics on the accuracy of the ABS system. But anecdotally, Fred DeHeses says it was pretty damn good. It was very accurate. There were times where you would go, ooh, but again, you did what that machine wanted. There's no dispute here. The ABS is more accurate.
它看起来就像球场上一个普通的下午。现在是伯纳德，右打对阵左投格鲁姆，全挥臂准备，第一球。目前没有关于ABS系统准确性的公开统计数据。但根据个人经验，弗雷德·德赫苏斯说它非常准。它非常准确。有时你会想“噢”，但话说回来，你按照那台机器的要求做了。这里没有什么好争论的。ABS比人类裁判更准确。
than a human umpire. Fred says there were some minor glitches when he used it, but nothing that can't be worked out by the time the system reaches the major leagues. The accuracy thing is huge because there's just so much money on the line. A bad call at the wrong time can ruin a player's career. And sports betting is such a huge industry now. I get why the major leagues want a more accurate system. But a few days after watching the robot umpire in action, my doubt started to be. to creep back in.
弗雷德说他在使用时遇到了一些小故障，但没有什么是在系统到达大联盟之前无法解决的。准确率这件事至关重要，因为有太多的资金悬于一线。在错误的时间做出一次糟糕的判罚可能会毁掉球员的职业生涯。而且现在体育博彩是一个如此庞大的产业。我理解为什么大联盟想要一个更准确的系统。但在观看机器人裁判实际运作几天后，我的疑虑开始重新浮现。
Because accuracy isn't everything. Here's Zach Helphund. I don't think most people watch sports to see the fairest or most accurate outcome. For me, the argument comes down to efficiency and accuracy versus charm and drama and dialogue. The thing is, for more than 100 years, Baseball has been played by humans and umpired by other humans.
因为准确率并不代表一切。这是扎克·赫尔芬德。我认为大多数人看体育比赛并不是为了看到最公平或最准确的结果。对我来说，争论的关键在于效率和准确性与魅力、戏剧性和对话之间的权衡。问题是，在100多年的时间里，棒球一直是由人类打的，并由其他人类裁判。
And in that process, we've introduced lots of small quirks and inefficiencies. For example, baseball stadiums don't have standard dimensions. So a home run at Fenway Park might just be a long flyball at Dodger Stadium. Baseball just has all these unstandardized things. One of them is the application of the strike zone. Again, the textbook strike zone is supposed to be the player's chess. to their knees over the plate. But most human umpires don't exactly follow those guidelines.
在这个过程中，我们引入了许多小的怪癖和低效之处。例如，棒球球场没有标准尺寸。所以在芬威球场的一个本垒打在道奇球场可能只是一记高飞球。棒球就是有所有这些非标准化的东西。其中之一就是好球区的应用。同样，教科书上的好球区应该是球员在过本垒板时胸部到膝盖的区域。但大多数人类裁判并不完全遵循这些准则。
There's lots of pitches that are considered hitable that don't land inside the textbook strike zone. And human umpires usually call those strikes. But the robot umpire, they've been slower to pick that up. In 2019, the ABS system was introduced to the Atlantic League, and it was programmed to call the textbook strike zone. But most fans and players thought the system felt, Off. The robot was calling a lot of hitable pitches as balls. So when the strike zone is, you know, so coldly unchanging, that sometimes presented some problems. When the strike zone is smaller than what you're used to, games can drag on.
有许多被认为是可击打的球并没有落在教科书式的好球区内。而人类裁判通常把这些球判为好球。但是机器人裁判，它们接受这一点的速度较慢。2019年，ABS系统被引入大西洋联盟，它被编程为呼叫教科书式的好球区。但大多数球迷和球员认为这个系统感觉“不对劲”。机器人把许多可击打的球判成了坏球。所以当好球区如此冷冰冰地一成不变时，有时就会带来一些问题。当好球区比你习惯的要小时，比赛就会被拖长。
Zach Elfin says the league needed to reprogram the ABS to be less accurate in how it called balls and strikes. They expanded it to about maybe an inch or an inch and a half off of the play. counts as a strike, and that better represented what the real strike zone is. You can program the ABS to call a less accurate game, but you can't program it to do all these other things that human umpires just do instinctively. So I'm going to let you in on a little dirty baseball secret. Umpires are constantly changing the strike zone based on context. It's raining. Let's move this along. Let's get this over with. Or one team is up by a lot. Let's just go. home, when a pitcher is struggling, there's a demonstrable effect that the umpire zone gets bigger.
扎克·埃尔芬说，联盟需要重新对ABS进行编程，使其在判罚好球和坏球时“没那么准确”。他们把它扩大到了本垒板外大约一英寸或一英寸半的范围也算作好球，这更好地代表了真正的好球区是什么样的。你可以将ABS编程为判罚一场准确度较低的比赛，但你无法将其编程为能够做到人类裁判凭直觉就能做到的所有其他事情。所以我要告诉你一个棒球界的阴暗小秘密。裁判会根据语境不断改变好球区。下雨了？让我们快点吧。让我们赶紧结束吧。或者有一支球队领先很多？让我们早点回家吧。当投手陷入困境时，有一个明显的效果，那就是裁判的好球区会变大。
Sometimes it gets as much as 50% bigger. That's what they call the compassionate umpire effect. So a pitcher's having a really tough time, we're going to help them out. And they don't do this consciously. When you leave it up to the machines to decide balls and strikes, you're ignoring years of training and experience and intuition that every great umpire has. And you're taking away one of those small imperfections that makes, basically, baseball kind of romantic.
有时它会变大高达50%。这就是所谓的“同情裁判效应”。所以当一个投手处境非常艰难时，我们会帮他们一把。他们不是刻意这样做的。当你把决定好球和坏球的权力留给机器时，你就忽视了每个伟大裁判多年来接受的训练、经验和直觉。并且你剥夺了那些让棒球变得有点浪漫的小瑕疵。
There is a trade-off because you do lose this discussion. You do lose these quirks, these injustices, these twists of fate where someone blinks or gets dirt in their eye and they make a bad call and that changes everything. I want to see how people react to that. We watch baseball to feel something to divert ourselves. And sometimes it's nice to feel righteously mad against an empire or to feel like you got away with something. Okay, but let's talk about righteous anger for a minute. Because Zach is totally right. Yelling at the umpire is a part of the game.
这是一个权衡，因为你确实失去了这种讨论。你确实失去了这些怪癖、这些不公、这些命运的转折——有人眨了眼或眼睛里进了沙子，从而做出了一个糟糕的判罚，而这改变了一切。我想看看人们对此有何反应。我们看棒球是为了感受某些东西，为了自我消遣。有时，对裁判感到正义的愤怒，或者感觉自己侥幸过关，也是一种美好的体验。好吧，但我们来谈谈正义的愤怒。因为扎克完全是对的。对裁判大喊大叫是比赛的一部分。
Umpires get yelled at by fans and players and mascots pretty much nonstop. Because unlike other sports, baseball centers the umpire. The umpire is right behind the plate making judgment calls on every play. And usually the yelling is fun and cathartic and professional empires can handle it, but it sucks to experience that. Here's Katie Nolan. Imagine going to work knowing you could get a shard of wood directly into your face, or you could get hit by a 100 mile per hour projectile in the face on a bad day.
裁判几乎不间断地受到球迷、球员和吉祥物的吼叫。因为与其他运动不同，棒球以裁判为中心。裁判就站在本垒后面，对每一次判罚做出判断。通常这种吼叫是有趣且发泄性的，专业裁判也能应付，但经历这种感觉真的很糟。这是凯蒂·诺兰。想象一下去上班，明知道自己可能会被飞来的木片直接击中脸部，或者在倒霉的一天，脸部会被一个时速100英里的飞行物击中。
And on a good ceiling of this job is like you make calls that get people to tell you that you suck at your job and you're the worst and you ruined the game. You know, I've got a video on Instagram right now that's got over 3 million views where the player is saying, Freddie, you're the worst umpire in the league. How did they mic you up? Now, he's obviously joking, but this is what the world wants to hear. They want umpires to be ridicule. And it's not just ridicule.
而在顺利的一天里，这份工作的极限就是你做出的判罚会让人们对你说你工作烂透了，你是最差的，你毁了比赛。你知道的，我Instagram上现在有一个视频有超过300万次观看，其中球员在说：“弗雷迪，你是联盟里最烂的裁判。他们是怎么给你装上麦克风的？”现在，他显然是在开玩笑，但这正是世界想听到的。他们希望裁判成为被嘲笑的对象。而且这不仅仅是嘲笑。
There are stories of umpires receiving death threats or even being physically assaulted by fans. Tonight is Staten Island parent coach is accused of punching the empire so hard it left him with a broken jaw. CBS2's Lisa Rosner spoke with friends of the umpire. People get carried. away and it can get scary.
有报道称裁判收到死亡威胁，甚至遭到球迷的身体攻击。今晚，斯塔滕岛的一位家长兼教练被指控拳击裁判，力度之大导致其下巴骨折。CBS2的丽莎·罗斯纳采访了裁判的朋友们。人们会失去理智，这可能会变得很可怕。
I remembered this Littly game where I made a really bad third strike call and after the game, a coach was waiting to yell at me in the parking lot. The abuse is actually the primary reason that I stopped umpiring. And it's why my favorite thing
我记得有一次小联盟比赛，我做出了一个非常糟糕的三振判罚，赛后，一个教练在停车场等着对我大喊大叫。这种辱骂实际上是我停止当裁判的主要原因。这也是为什么我最喜欢
about the robot umps isn't their accuracy. It's their ability to bring down the temperature. Zach Helton noticed this too when he saw a robot umpire in person. fans were a lot less likely to get into arguments when they knew it was a machine making the calls. Some fans who, as fans do,
机器人裁判的特点不是它们的准确性。而是它们降低火药味的能力。扎克·赫尔芬德在亲眼看到机器人裁判时也注意到了这一点。当球迷知道是机器人在做判罚时，他们就不太可能卷入争论中。有些球迷，正如球迷常做的那样，
and as is part of the pleasure of baseball, were heckling the umpire when I was out there. At one point, one of the fans who did know that they were using robo umpires this season in that league pointed up at the hardware above home plate and said, you know, it's not the umpire. This is just the strike zone. and the fan was humiliated in a certain way, very humbled,
这也是棒球乐趣的一部分，当我站在场上时，他们还在对裁判起哄。有一刻，其中一个知道本赛季联盟中使用机器人裁判的球迷指着本垒上方的硬件说：“你知道的，这不是裁判。这只是好球区。”那个球迷在某种程度上感到很尴尬，非常谦卑，
and was like, you know what, it's actually calling a pretty good game. Watching the Isotopes Chihuahua's game, I remember this one at bat. So the Isotopes third baseman Taylor Snyder was at the plate. Count still one in two. Bases juiced. Here's the pitch. Takes a cult third strike breaking ball inside corner. That ends the inning.
并说：“你知道吗，它其实判得挺不错的。”观看同位素队对阵吉娃娃队的比赛时，我记得有这么一次打席。同位素队的三垒手泰勒·斯奈德当时在打击区。球数仍然是一好两坏。满垒。投球来了。接住了一个内角弧线球被判第三好球。这结束了这一局。
Isotopes do not score. So the batter, Snyder, he disagreed with the call. He thought it was inside, and he was clearly furious. He starts to turn towards the ump, and it looks like he is ready to yell. But then he didn't. He stopped himself. And he walked back to the dugout. I'd never seen that before.
同位素队没有得分。所以打者斯奈德不同意这个判罚。他认为那是个内角球，显然非常愤怒。他开始转身面向裁判，看起来准备大喊大叫。但他没有。他克制住了自己。然后他走回了休息区。我以前从未见过这种情况。
And for me, that's a big plus for the idea of robot umbs. Ultimately, the robot umpires are coming. They're going to be used in all AAA games this season. Some games will use a full robot umpire system, while others will use the robot umpire as an appeal system if the player doesn't like a call. Robot umpires are probably going to show up in the major leagues in the next couple of years. And I know baseball purists are going to be really mad. I get that.
对我来说，这是机器人裁判概念的一个巨大加分项。归根结底，机器人裁判的时代即将来临。它们将在本赛季所有的3A比赛中使用。有些比赛将使用完整的机器人裁判系统，而另一些比赛则将在球员对判罚不满意时将机器人裁判用作申诉系统。机器人裁判很可能会在未来几年内出现在大联盟中。我知道棒球纯粹主义者会非常愤怒。我懂。
I don't love the general idea of robots muscling in on human jobs. But I think I can live with this new technology. Because I'm in favor of anything that makes us see, umpires as people. Even if that thing is a robot. That story was first broadcast in 2023. Today, the robot umpire has officially been introduced at the major league level. And after the break, Chris Barube will tell us how it's going.
我不喜欢机器人涉足人类工作的总体想法。但我认为我可以接受这项新技术。因为我赞成任何能让我们把裁判看作是“人”的事物。即使那个事物是一个机器人。那个故事最初在2023年播出。今天，机器人裁判已正式引入大联盟水平。休息过后，克里斯·巴鲁贝将告诉我们进展如何。
So we're back with Chris Barube. Hey, Chris. Hey, Roman. So Chris, what has changed since we first broadcast that story? So the robot umpire has arrived in major league baseball, but not in the way that I was predicting, certainly that a lot of people were predicting. So remember, in that story, we talked about a system where the robot umpire makes all the calls and then the human umpire says it out loud, right?
我们又和克里斯·巴鲁贝在一起了。嘿，克里斯。嘿，罗曼。那么克里斯，自从我们首次播出那个故事以来，有什么变化？所以机器人裁判已经来到了美国职业棒球大联盟，但并不是以我预测的方式，当然也不是许多人预测的方式。所以记得在那个故事中，我们讨论了一个系统，其中机器人裁判做出所有判罚，然后人类裁判大声宣判，对吧？
Like they were trying that at the AAA level. So Major League Baseball is not doing that. Instead, they are using the robot umpire as a kind of challenge system. So right now, human umpires are still making every ball and strike call. But if a player disagrees, they can challenge the call. And then the automated balls and strikes will determine who was correct. So they're using the robot umpires, but humans are still doing most of the work. So this was not what I was expecting either.
就像他们在3A水平尝试的那样。所以美国职业棒球大联盟并没有那样做。相反，他们将机器人裁判用作一种挑战系统。所以现在，人类裁判仍然在做出每一个好球和坏球的判罚。但如果球员不同意，他们可以对判罚提出挑战。然后自动好坏球系统将决定谁是正确的。所以他们使用了机器人裁判，但人类仍在完成大部分工作。这也不是我所期望的。
So how does that end up working during the game? So, Roman, I've actually sent you a link with an ABS challenge from a game this week between Atlanta and the Kansas City Royals. So I want you to pull it up and narrate through. Like, what is it that you see? Okay, the pitch comes in. It looks a little low. Okay, the catcher taps his helmet. Okay, and then the umpire goes to the side to check what's happening.
那么这在比赛中到底是如何运作的呢？罗曼，我实际上给你发了一个链接，里面是本周亚特兰大和堪萨斯城皇家队比赛中的一次ABS挑战。我希望你打开它并进行解说。你看到了什么？好的，球投进来了。看起来有点低。好的，捕手敲了敲他的头盔。好的，然后裁判走到一边去查看发生了什么。
happening. All right. All right. And then they show a graphic of the ball. Just sort of hitting the bottom of the strike zone. As you can see, this is very close call. Yeah. I mean, the Empire does a really good job, actually. Yeah. That's a really close borderline call. So the fact the catcher knew to challenge that one is impressive. But yeah, yeah. Yeah. So that's what it looks like. It's like the ball comes in and then either the catcher or the hitter or the pitcher taps their head, taps their helmet with their hat. Wow. And then the umpire says, okay, there's a challenge on the field.
发生了什么。好的。好的。然后他们展示了一个球的图表。刚好击中了球区底部。正如你所看到的，这是一个非常接近的判罚。是的。我的意思是，裁判实际上做得很好。是的。这是一个非常接近的边缘判罚。所以捕手知道去挑战那个球，这令人印象深刻。但是，是的，是的。是的，这就是它的样子。就像球进来了，然后捕手、击球手或投手用帽子敲他们的头，敲他们的头盔。哇。然后裁判说，好的，场上有个挑战。
And then everybody looks up at the scoreboard and they show the graphic. Like within about 10 seconds, you know what happened. And then it shows the graphic. And then the ABS decides, okay, that just graced the strike zone. So that's a strike or, you know, that was actually outside. So that's a ball. So that's how it works. Okay.
然后每个人都抬头看记分牌，他们展示了图表。在大约10秒钟内，你知道发生了什么。然后它显示图表。然后ABS决定，好的，那个球刚好擦过好球区。所以那是个好球，或者，你知道的，那其实在外面。所以那是坏球。这就是它的运作方式。好的。
So my question is this, okay? How much does this slow the game down? Like baseball is not like a lightning fast game to begin with. You know what I mean? Because I would imagine. in, like, why wouldn't you challenge everything? You know, like, and therefore slow everything down even more. This is a really good point.
所以我的问题是，这会把比赛拖慢多少？棒球本来就不是一个快如闪电的比赛。你知道我的意思吗？因为我想象中。在那种情况下，为什么你不去挑战每一个球呢？你知道的，从而把一切拖得更慢。这是一个非常好的观点。
And I think this is what people were worried about with the introduction of the challenge system. But they've put in a rule to limit how often this happens. So each team only gets two challenges a game. But if you make a successful challenge, you get to keep it. So basically, each team gets the right to be wrong twice. So if you, you know, if you challenge and you're wrong, you lose that challenge for the rest of game. So it incentivizes really only picking your spots, like really only doing it on important plays or plays where you're like, I'm pretty sure I'm right about this one. That's right. You have to
我想这也是人们对引入挑战系统所担心的。但他们制定了一条规则来限制这种情况发生的频率。所以每支球队一场比赛只有两次挑战机会。但如果你挑战成功，你可以保留它。基本上，每支球队都有两次犯错的权利。所以如果你挑战了却错了，你在剩余的比赛中就会失去这个挑战机会。因此，它激励人们真正只挑选关键时机，真正只在重要的比赛中这样做，或者在你确信自己没错的判罚上这样做。没错。你必须
save your challenges for when it really matters. That's it. Yeah. So are people happy with this so far? I'd say for the most part, yes. So for players, like, this has been pretty good because, you know, before, if there was a bad call, they had to kind of grin and bear it and go back to the dugout and be angry. But now a few times a game, you know, they can get a call overturned. Like they have some recourse. So that's cool for them. The fans, for the most part, they seem pretty into it, which has been kind of a surprise. So this is anecdotal, like at the time of recording, we're one week into this experiment. But all the baseball fans in my life that I've spoken to have been like, huh, this is actually kind of fun. I'm surprised. What's fun about it? Well, I think what a lot of people
把挑战留到真正重要的时刻。就是这样。是的。那么人们到目前为止对此满意吗？我想大部分是的。对球员来说，这相当不错，因为以前如果有糟糕的判罚，他们只能咬牙切牙地忍着，回到休息区生闷气。但现在一场比赛几次，他们可以推翻一个判罚。他们有一些补救措施。所以这对他们来说很酷。球迷们大部分似乎也挺投入的，这有点令人惊讶。所以这只是坊间传闻，在录制时，我们正处于这个实验的第一周。但我与之交过的所有棒球迷朋友都说：“嗯，这其实挺有意思的。我很惊讶。”这有什么有趣的？嗯，我想很多人
were worried about was how this would affect the drama of the game, right? Because instead of having a human make calls, you'd have, you know, a clinical robot making the calls. But it's actually creating more drama, which is because a couple times a game now, a player will say, oh, you thought that was a strike. I think that was a ball. And then everybody looks up at the scoreboard together. And then, like, fans go crazy when their team is right, you know, in their challenges. So it's not what I was worried. about, which was, oh, it's going to be a human versus robot. That's kind of a boring conflict. Instead, it is this moment of player versus umpire with the robot as the arbitrator. And that's actually kind of fun. It's kind of fun to watch that happen. I mean, actually does sound fun. So how are the umpires
担心的是这会如何影响比赛的戏剧性，对吧？因为不再是由人类做判罚，而是由一个冰冷的机器来做判罚。但它实际上创造了更多的戏剧性，因为现在一场比赛中有几次，球员会说：“哦，你以为那是好球。我认为那是坏球。”然后大家一起抬头看记分牌。接着，当他们的球队在挑战中获胜时，球迷们就会疯狂。所以这并不是我担心的那样，即“哦，这将是人与机器的对抗”。那是一个无聊的冲突。相反，它是球员与裁判的时刻，而机器人则是仲裁者。这其实挺有趣的。看这个发生挺有趣的。我的意思是，这听起来确实很有趣。那么裁判们是怎么
taking it? Well, that is a different story. So obviously, no active major league umpires have said anything about it yet. I'm sure they're still in, you know, kind of a wait and see phase. And, you know, you don't want to risk your job by saying something about Major League Baseball. But a couple of retired umpires have given interviews. And basically what they've said is like, I feel terrible for the umpires right now. Because if you think about this from an umpire's perspective, this cannot be good for your self-esteem, right? Or for your reputation? Because if you're an umpire, several times a game now, someone questions your judgment, and then everybody looks up at a giant scoreboard to see if you blew it.
看待它的？嗯，那是另一回事了。显然，还没有活跃的大联盟裁判对此发表任何意见。我确信他们仍然处于某种“骑墙观望”的阶段。而且，你也不想通过对美国职业棒球大联盟说三道四来冒丢工作的风险。但几位退役裁判接受了采访。他们基本上所说的是：“我现在为裁判感到难过。”因为如果你从裁判的角度考虑这一点，这对你的自尊心绝对没有好处，对吧？或者对你的声誉？因为如果你是一个裁判，现在一场比赛有好几次，有人质疑你的判断，然后每个人都抬头看一个巨大的记分牌，看看你是不是搞砸了。
And if you blew it, everyone cheers. Like 30,000 people are cheering for a mistake that you made. And for the accurate umpires, like, doesn't really matter that much. But for the ones who make mistakes more often, like, there's a couple of umpires who have been genuinely humiliated by the ABS system. And we're only a week into this so far. Yeah, that doesn't sound fun at all. Yeah. So I want to show you an example of this, Roman.
如果你搞砸了，所有人都在欢呼。就像三万人为你的一个错误欢呼。对于那些准确的裁判来说，其实没那么重要。但对于那些更容易犯错的裁判来说，有几个裁判确实被ABS系统严重羞辱了。而我们现在才进入第一周。是的，听起来一点也不有趣。是的。所以我想给你展示一个这方面的例子，罗曼。
I want to turn your attention to the case of CB Buckner versus Augenio Suarez. So C.B. Buckner is an umpire. He's been in the league for about 26 years. And A. Eugenio Suarez is the third baseman for the Cincinnati Reds. And earlier this week, when we're recording this, they had a bit of a notorious dustup involving ABS. Okay. Let's watch it. So here we are. We are in Cincinnati. And this pitch is clearly low.
我想把你的注意力转向CB·巴克纳对阵奥赫尼奥·苏亚雷斯的案例。CB·巴克纳是一名裁判。他在联盟呆了大约26年。奥赫尼奥·苏亚雷斯是辛辛那提红人队的三垒手。就在本周早些时候，在我们录制这个节目时，他们经历了一次与ABS有关的著名冲突。好的。我们来看看。所以我们在这里。我们在辛辛那提。这个球明显偏低。
A. Eugenio Suarez taps his helmet to indicate he wants a challenge. Buckner looks out to the audience to say the call is being challenged. Then we look up with the scoreboard. And it's pretty obvious that this one was like a little bit outside the zone. So Suarez was right. Call gets overturned. This was a third strike call too. So this would have ended the inning, but instead he gets another pitch.
奥赫尼奥·苏亚雷斯敲击他的头盔，表示他想要挑战。巴克纳向观众示意判罚正在受到挑战。然后我们抬头看记分牌。很明显，这个球在好球区外面一点。所以苏亚雷斯是对的。判罚被推翻了。这也是一个第三好球的判罚。所以这本该结束这一局，但他得到了另一个投球。
And then it happens again, a pitch later. So there's another pitch outside the zone. Suarez challenges again. Buckner's looking pretty upset. He talks to the audience. He's like, all right, I guess we're doing this again. And it's pretty obvious he was even more wrong this time. And now the crowd's losing it.
然后几球之后又发生了。又是一个好球区外的球。苏亚雷斯再次挑战。巴克纳看起来很不高兴。他跟观众说话。他好像在说：“好吧，我想我们又要来一次了。”很明显，他这次错得更离谱了。现在观众都疯狂了。
They're like, yeah. Now, obviously, this is great drama, right? And for the fans, this is cool because it's like, you get to challenge. And it's like, we were right. The umpire's wrong. Are you blind? You know, all this stuff. Yeah, yeah, sure.
他们就像是：“太棒了。”当然，这很有戏剧性，对吧？对于球迷来说，这很酷，因为你可以挑战。结果是我们赢了。裁判错了。你瞎了吗？你知道的，所有这些。是的，是的，当然。
But for this umpire, you know, he had a whole stadium full of people cheering because he did a bad job at work. Right. Yeah. And this clip went super viral. I did not know the name C.B. Buckner before this week. And now everybody in baseball knows who he is, right? There have been all these articles that are like, here's another thing. CB Buckner did.
但对这个裁判来说，全体育场的人都在为他在工作上表现糟糕而欢呼。对吧。是的。这个视频在网上疯传。在这周之前我根本不知道CB·巴克纳的名字。现在棒球界的每个人都知道他是谁了，对吧？有所有这些文章都在写：“这是CB·巴克纳搞砸的又一件事。”
And this probably would not have happened without the ABS system challenging his calls. Yeah. Yeah. That sounds very rough for him. My heart goes out to CB. Yeah, it's about to get worse. So CB Buckner in that game got six calls overturned. So this happened to him six times.
如果没有ABS系统挑战他的判罚，这可能不会发生。是的。是的。对他来说这听起来太残酷了。我的心与CB同在。是的，情况会更糟。所以CB·巴克纳在那场比赛中有六次判罚被推翻了。所以这在他身上发生了六次。
And now basically anytime he does something wrong, there's people on social media and people in the baseball media being like, C.B. Buckner screws up again. And a contextual note, CB Buckner is one of the few. few black umpires in baseball. So this is obviously not ideal that this is the person coming in for so much criticism. I should know he is a below average umpire. Like anybody who does the like tracking of umpire accuracy says like C.B. Buckner doesn't have a great eye, but like you gotta feel bad for this guy.
现在基本上只要他做错任何事，社交媒体上和棒球媒体上就会有人说：“CB·巴克纳又搞砸了。”顺便说一句，CB·巴克纳是棒球界为数不多的黑人裁判之一。所以这个人受到如此多的批评，显然不是理想的情况。我应该指出，他是一个低于平均水平的裁判。任何追踪裁判准确性的人都会说“CB·巴克纳的视力不是很好”，但你确实得为这家伙感到难过。
And then later in the week he got hitting the mask by a foul tip. Like there was a foul ball that hit him in the face and he had to leave a game. So, you know, when it reads it pores for this guy, like you got to feel for this guy on a human level. Absolutely. He's just having the worst week ever. My sympathies, for sure. Yeah, me too. And when we did this original story, I came out softly on the side of robot umpires because I thought it would help people see umpires, like the humans as human beings, right? Because it would take out some of this, like vitriol against umpires in the game.
然后在本周晚些时候，他的面具被界外球击中了。有一个界外球击中了他的脸，他不得不离开比赛。所以，屋漏偏逢连夜雨，你真的得在人类层面上同情这家伙。绝对的。他正经历着最糟糕的一周。我绝对同情他。是的，我也是。当我们制作这个原创故事时，我轻微地倾向于机器人裁判这一边，因为我认为这会帮助人们把裁判看作是人——作为真正的人类，对吧？因为这会消除一些对比赛中裁判的恶毒攻击。
But in this particular case, it's kind of doing the opposite. Like it has put this person under a microscope. It has empowered people to, you know, yell at this guy and be. mean to him on social media and stuff. And, you know, C.B. Buckner's a grown man. You know, comes with the territory. But, like, it has kind of done the opposite of what I was thinking the robot umpires would accomplish. Yeah. Yeah. So I guess we'll just have to watch the rest of season and see how it goes for all the other umpires. But I'm totally intrigued. Thanks for the primer. Of course. And I hope we've given everybody some extra context when you're watching a baseball game
但在这种特定情况下，它起到了相反的作用。它把这个人放在了显微镜下。它赋予了人们大声呵斥这个家伙并在社交媒体上对刻薄对他的权力。你知道的，CB·巴克纳是个成年人。你知道的，这在所难免。但是，这有点违背了我认为机器人裁判会达到的初衷。是的。所以我想我们只需要观看赛季剩下的比赛，看看其他裁判情况如何。但我完全被迷住了。谢谢你的入门介绍。不客气。我希望我们能在大家观看棒球比赛时提供一些额外的背景信息
this summer. Awesome. Well, thank you, Chris. Thanks, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barrupe. The 2023 episode was edited by Kelly Prime and fact-checked by Graham Hesha, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Rial. You can find Zach Halfen's article about robot umpires in The New Yorker. His latest feature story is about airport lounges. It is a must read for fans of 99PIA. You're going to love it. Katie Nolan has recently launched a new sports podcast called Casuals.
考虑到迕回连接时的延迟，请确认你已经做好准备。
You can find it wherever you get your podcasts. Our executive producer is Kathy, too. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashma Don, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars.
我们的执行制片人是凯莉·图。我们的高级编辑是德兰妮·霍尔
The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on blue sky as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99% Invisible 的标志是由史芬·劳伦斯创作的。